the Russo brothers are back at it again
in the days leading up to their
appearance at this year's San Diego
comic-con which takes place from July
18th to July 21st Avengers infinity war
and Avengers endgame directors Joe and
Anthony Russo have taken the social
media to tease what they'll be showing
off at the highly anticipated
entertainment convention what started
off simply has turned into something
much bigger and fans are going
absolutely bonkers over the Russo's most
recent tease things began innocently
when the sibling filmmakers shed an
Instagram photo of the San Diego
comic-con logo as a way to confirm that
they'll be presenting their own panel a
conversation with the Russo brothers
which will be held on Friday July 19th
at 11 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
then the teasing evolved when the Russo
brothers shared a video with text that
read oh 7 1919 and background audio from
2017 San Diego comic-con where a snippet
of Avengers infinity war played out for
the attendees in Hall H naturally Marvel
lights began speculating that the
Russo's panel could include some
exclusive footage from past Marvel
movies that theory changed in the
directing devote posted another video of
audio from community a sitcom the
executive produced in the years before
they became MCU icons abundant is that
biblioteca me llamo t-bone langya
discoteca fans Minds began racing Amala
minutes then went into overdrive with
the Russo brothers third and most recent
SDCC teased a video containing audio
from Arrested Development's yet another
television series r2 worked on pre
Marvel in the video Jeffrey tumbles
character delivers his iconic mini
monologue how much clearer can I say
there's always money
some fans are of the opinion that the
Russos might confirm our community film
is in the works while others believe
that they'll announce season six of
Arrested Development's still others
believe that they'll offer an update on
Arrested Development movie that's been
coming together since 2009 one fan
pointed out that the Russos definitely
have the money to fund the community
movie an Arrested Development film or
both they might even be using their
earnings from Avengers endgame which has
grossed over two point seventy eight
billion dollars worldwide as of July
16th to revisit their old works anyway
it's us their fans are flipping over the
Russo brothers pre San Diego comic-con
teasers but there truly is no telling
exactly what they have planned for their
convention panel all we know is that
colliders editor-in-chief Steve
Weintraub is moderating the presentation
which is officially billed as being a
reflection of the Russo's time filming
Avengers endgame and a look into how
they were transitioning to life beyond
marvel with their production company AGB
oh there's a chance that a gbo could be
the studio behind the community movie or
an Arrested Development film and that
when the panel discussion shifts to AGB
oh the Russos would unveil one or both
of those projects one likely won't be
featured during a conversation with the
Russo brothers as any talk of Marvel's
phase four plans since that will
presumably be reserved from Marvel
Studios for hate panel on Saturday July
20th at 5:15 p.m. Pacific Standard Time
the notoriously secret studio hasn't
confirmed anything about its film
schedule past spider-man far from home
the phase 3 ender that swung into
theaters at the start of July a handful
of movies notably the Eternals and the
Black Widow solo film have already begun
taking shape but Marvel is essentially
pretending that they don't exist for the
time being whatever happens at the
Russos personal panel it probably won't
be MCU related check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
loop of videos but your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]